it was important to Daniel when he when
we started the show when he came to me
initially the kind of character comedy
that he wanted which was kind of a you
know it kind of grounded in reality the
kind of films that I did with Chris
guest is is the kind of comedic tone
that we wanted for the show how do you
put her on speaker speaker speaker yeah
hello Mara
John are you there kid say hi to your
mother
hey the sort of format of the show was
that season after season who would be
sort of peeling back the layers on these
characters as the audience gets to know
them so the sort of through line of the
more the audience watches they sort of
you know the characters reveal
themselves in real time with the people
watching at home
okay well I'll try not to sweetheart
lots to do but wishing you an exciting
okay yep miss you too she already hung
up burn dad that's so embarrassing you
must feel ridiculous and I really feel
like that's why five seasons later the
audience's the the fans of the show feel
that kind of investment because it's
been a gradual love between the viewer
in the show and the characters and you
know it's it's been it's been really fun